james duddridge is uh with me now mp for
rochford and south and west been mr
dodgers you've been with the pm all day
you said in your statement he's buoyant
is he really boying he is point he's up
for a fight and he knows he's going to
be difficult but he asked me to leave
him
down the street come over here tell
members of parliament that he's listened
but he's up for a fight he's going to
make some changes he's going to make
some cabinet appointments today i wasn't
in on the meeting but i'm told he sank
michael gove um there's a number of
other appointments to be made he uh will
be engaging with that you know today as
we we go through nadeem sir hawaii's uh
solidly behind him uh so reports there
were wrong he's going to announce a new
uh economic strategy that's going to
happen sometime next week but as a
tax-cutting conservative i'm really
pleased to say that there will
definitely be tax cuts uh in that speech
i don't know the details we'll have to
wait for that but that is the red meat
that the back benches wanted we're going
to seize him coming out fighting making
some changes making tax cuts and moving
forward he's got a 14 million mandate
from the british public he now needs to
deliver that now is not the time to have
a stupid election and look introverted
this is a time to worry about the issue
of ukraine to get the tax cuts to get
the economy back on track and move
forward and he really is up for it i
think a lot of people might say the red
meat is the sucking of michael gove i
mean you slip that in there in the
middle of your answer as it was just a
minor thing why has he sacked michael
gove i don't know i was i wasn't i
wasn't i have an idea i was going around
saying that michael gove's a disloyal
so-and-so i genuinely don't know mr goh
has become uh the first person i can
think of to be sacked by three prime
ministers david cameron sacked him as
education secretary theresa may sacked
him when she became prime minister and
now boris johnson my job is not to be
disrespectful of colleagues is simply to
pass on the mood of the prime minister
and say what he's he's doing there were
question marks over what he was going to
do after the meetings in downing street
it's been very clear he's moving forward
14 million now we've heard the pm talk
about that you've mentioned it a couple
of times
that's all very well but the fact is he
doesn't appear to have the support of
many cabinet ministers and we believe a
majority of conservative backbenchers
it doesn't matter about the 14 million
majority mandate does it surely what
matters the electorate that matters
right now is tory mps and they've turned
on him well it's clearly somehow and and
the message for
many people
yeah well that we will appoint new
ministers so there's plenty
within the party well i'm not going to
go through the cabinet reshuffle but i
know that there are plenty of people
keen willing and able to serve and will
do so under boris johnson um brandon
lewis we believe has gone into number 10
is he getting a new job what's he
getting i i i don't know i'm not in
charge of the prime minister's
appointments diary take us through the
prime minister's day because you said
you've been with him all day i mean who
were you i haven't been where are you
for example when the cabinet minister
said to him time's up boris you've got
to go and i don't recognize the reports
of a cabinet all being in the room with
the prime minister oh so was it one by
one i did i just i i
i wasn't in a meeting i don't know about
that meeting but we've had it confirmed
by senior members of parliament that um
when i was told by a very very senior mp
that the cabinet went in and said to him
prime minister game's up time to go and
he said no i'm not going right that's
correct isn't it i i don't know if
that's correct well i told him
i can only say what i know yeah um so
what i do know is a number of cabinet
people turned up they had chats with his
team they had a chat with him um various
points um and he made it clear that he
was fighting on why are you staying
loyal
well because boris johnson is right for
the country and right for the party i
mean he's got an electoral uh magic that
he showed as mayor of london i believe
he'll deliver brexit i believe he's uh
the best person still i mean no one's
perfect and clearly he has made some
mistakes um but he can move on from this
and one of the things the parts we want
are tax cuts and i think that's really
going to reassure people um we didn't
see much electoral magic in
tibetan and hunterton wakefield before
that shropshire north i mean it seems to
be the three p's have done for him
paterson partygate and now pincher and
he's made a right hash of all three
hasn't he well mid midterm we always
lose by elections
more recent ones are uh are an anathema
in many ways we're back to business as
usual people are done people are going
back to business as usual businesses in
relation to violence we've got about 40
kept 40 ministers from ranging from
senior cabinet ministers to parliament i
was just talking about by-elections oh
okay but it's not business as usual is
it well there's an army there's a moon
must be a mood of crisis
you say that but there is business usual
things happening the prime minister has
been signing he's spoken to
international leaders he's had his
regular meetings as usual yeah well
that's his weekly audience yeah exactly
that is business as usual there is the
business to be getting on with he has
consulted with his cabinet he's staying
and he's taking things forward you
haven't even got enough ministers for
dcms questions and attorney general's
questions tomorrow one of the dcs
ministers has quit and the solicitor
general's quote you're telling me
they're going to be replaced tonight
there's going to be some major
appointments made tonight i don't know
whether that i don't think they'll all
be made tonight i mean it's 10 o'clock
so that that is unlikely now danny
kruger son of the famous tv chef
um he's going to leave a sour taste in
number 10 because he's just quit what
about that
what what was danny kruger doing he's
quit because of mike
i'm sorry i mean he's not a minister but
he's a pps oh right sorry well i mean
pps is i say this as a pps it's the
lowest form of promotion it's an unpaid
role helping your boss now mr kruger is
saying it should be the prime minister
going not mr gove
i mean don't danny i spoke to danny
today um and and passed on the message
to the prime minister that he thought he
should go and there are people that
think he should danny's one of them um
that's a perfectly understandable view
for some people to have i don't agree
with that there's a number of colleagues
that don't agree uh with that and the
prime minister thinks that he can go on
and deliver and get those numbers you
talked about appointments tonight are
you expecting more sackings tonight
um i've i've not heard any a talk of
anyone being sacked as i say the news
about michael gove was was news to me i
was interested in that he's going back
to mr gove i mean that is a major move
by the prime minister and clearly he
believes that mr gove is either he's
making a mess of levelling up
or
he's disloyal treacherous he wasn't in
pmq's as far as we can see he hasn't
been
acting as a cheerleader for the prime
minister so presumably mr gove has been
sacked for disloyalty that was why
theresa may sacked him after all she
said go on to the go to the back benches
and learn how to be loyal
if it wasn't for michael's actions which
he now regrets uh boris would have been
a leadership candidate and remained in
and probably would have got in instead
of theresa may so you think that mr gove
is disloyal to boris johnson well where
he had been his lord boris johnson he
regrets that decision then i i can't
speak for today